hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on monster on a world
again for another solo guide and today
we're gonna be talking about Zeno Jeeva
or Zeno as they said in the story
hopefully I pronounced this right or
this whole video is gonna be really bad
but he's gonna be the last monster you
fight in the main story of monster on
her world he only has two fighting rooms
but a lot of moves that he use and some
alternate attacks depending on the face
so let's get started
according to the report is head legs
wings and tail are either breakable or
separable with the head tail and legs
being his weak point it is recommended
you aim for the head and tail because
that does the most damage for every
weapon type available on the right side
he he is a two-star for all elements so
choose whatever you want and he's most
weak to poison and blast being in the
ailment section for the gear vitality
mantle is the obvious choice since it
negates him damage while wearing it and
mega potions for the health and that's
really about it easy no flies at certain
points but he isn't affected by flash
pods and since he is an elder dragon he
cannot be captured and affected by traps
since there are only two areas I'm going
to be explaining this alongside with
some of the moves but either way let's
get to the move set and let's see what
he has so quick tip if you're gonna hit
Z Knossos feet watch out he will try to
rotate to face you or jump away entirely
causing some minor damage so be careful
when you're attacking his feet and you
can tell where his weak points are in
his body because they are very bright
blue areas only the front legs will give
you decent damage but in the second
phase his hind legs will also do the
same amount of damage as the front legs
but we'll get into that a little bit
later be the way the first area is
pretty open with a small ledge even
though I'm pretty sure Dino cannot be
mounted so this area it pretty much
doesn't serve as much of an advantage to
you but the first move in his moveset is
this charge move he will stomp and
sprint towards you so very super easy to
dodge since he only goes in a straight
line move a bit to the side and you'll
be just fine
another move is this arm sweep move he
will swipe for his arm from right to
left so backing away should prevent some
of you from taking damage he will also
do a quick tail slamming for behind him
so definitely watch out for that next
move is this triple blast known for it
shoots three blue balls of you it would
always be forward left and right if
you're facing the same direction as the
monster dodging the blast would be
enough to prevent the on top of the slam
he will also do a tail sweep from right
to left you can either back away or rush
ahead to get underneath him before he
hits
you Xena will sometimes stand on his
hind legs and when he does he can do a
variety of different moves one being
this blue laser the path is a good start
short from right to left then moves up
far from left to right
Yuri rush the clip shown if you're
confused on the path next up is a
similar move to the blue blast except
people shoot a blue best about six times
once again simply dodging won't be fine
he doesn't do this very often but it
does come out here most likely ended
with that slow with a slam and he goes
in his hind legs and slammed his stomach
down so try to be around him and not
underneath when this happens another
move he will do is this laser beam move
this usually occurs when you're far away
there are two variations of this one one
that is straightforward and one that
goes from right to left dodged by
running to your right away from the
blast or charged him since this move
leaves him very open when doing so
eventually Xena is going to get pissed
off and go into his second phase you
could tell because his chest is now
bright red instead of a lightish purple
in this face he would leave trails of
fire everywhere which will cause fire
damage if you walk through them simply
rolling through these three times will
extinguish the flames also like we
mentioned before in this normal phase
his handlings weren't worth much since
they did less damage but in this second
phase the hind legs take the same amount
of damage so use this opportunity to hit
those back legs as much as possible
since it is a lot safer than hitting the
front legs for his second phase
alternative move set he can slam on the
floor like normal and then push his
claws in for some explosive damage time
the explosion and rush into slices hind
legs since the front legs will move
around a lot during this animation and
the back legs stay still as shown in the
clip I went for the front legs by
accident and didn't get much damage as
they kept moving when I should have went
for the back because they're completely
still another move is this blast attack
again except a little bit different like
normal it goes from right to left at a
short distance then left to right at a
far distance but then comes back around
to be a super short distance from right
to left as shown in the clip to where it
almost hits his own feet doing this move
will cause the ground to crumble on him
and he will fall over leaving him to
some free hits be careful not to be too
close or you will be affected like I am
in this clip and not get any damaging at
all eventually after some time Xena will
fly away from the area after a second or
two a winged rake will come by and pick
you up and drop you into the next area
the second area isn't much help except a
few rocks and some gems that make some
excellent
cover said Liese no can break these
leaving you with less cover so make sure
to prevent that by luring him away if
you need them in the second area as well
he has some new moves that he won't use
in the first area for some reason Xena
will fly in the air and attack you from
there he will shoot a few blue blasts
see you and then a straight line while
in the air he will also attempt to try
and swipe you from the air like in the
clip shown running away or rolling will
work against these attacks other than
that he will use the same moves from
both phases we talked about in the first
area so definitely watch out for those
as well and that is everything you need
to know about Zeno this is a pretty
quick video hope you guys did enjoy that
those are all the moves that I saw
during my couple playthroughs of this as
well as a little bit of a detailed
description on the area even though
there really wasn't much to go off of
since they are very to big open areas
but either way guys if you did enjoy the
video be sure to give it a like really
does help me out subscribe if you're new
I post a lot of monster on our world
content I do a lot of I'm gonna be start
doing some guides I'm doing these solo
guides as well but some other gods like
builds and stuff like that as I start to
get more into the game and get a lot
more material and decorations I'm gonna
start getting better guides for actual
builds but too much just in Monster
Hunter World videos are gonna be on
screen if you guys didn't miss those
highly recommend you check those out I
went that guy's hope you have a great
rest your day and peace out